everybody has sharded before oh now you
want to come back I'm telling your mom I
did not know it was just
diarrhea beautiful hey I'm Eric Nom and
today I'm going to be playing with some
puppies at
BuzzFeed I'm really nervous and really
excited I don't know what happens they
just like walk on in here no way they
just like wander in here they're just
like little munchkin doggies that just
be like hey I can't hold on I need to
mentally prepare myself
okay where did they come from do they
like parachute in oh my God oh my
God so cute hey hey little buddies hi
there's another one hi hey oh my God he
can be good morning hi what's up come
here hey little nugget hi those are
where are you going give me attention
give me love come here
hey I'm going to pick you up do you mind
I'm going to hold you real quick that
one's very apprehensive I'm very nervous
or curious ready for the first question
oh my God wait right we're doing things
right give me the
questions I just finished blood hounds
on Netflix and I'm about to start I
heard celebrity and mask girl are really
good so those are on my oh my God I know
they're on my list but aside from that
I've been watching this thing blue
something where it's like how to live
longer and I'm re-watching Stanley Tucci
searching for Italy he guys can you
include me in your little play date over
there no hey hey
hey oh he just took a little pee
pee Oh don't drink it don't drink the
pee Oh
no hey hey you dude uh I think if I
called right now we're in La it's
morning Chloe Kim would pick up right
[Music]
now I would pick the guys of smartless
Jason baitman will Arnette and sea Hayes
I think they're hilarious it's one of my
favorite podcasts so I would love to
talk to
them I think on stage I want to be a
little flashy but also very free flowing
so anything that gives me a lot of space
to move and then when it comes to like
shoots or videos I think it's pretty
conceptual in terms of what the vibe is
Right little man are you dancing look at
him he's dancing I've been trying to be
as experimental as possible just trying
on different things right now we're
having kind of a fake faux leather
moment where I'm wearing a lot of really
hot not breathable things I did a
performance the other day and I'm
telling you my legs were
swamped I carry a pillow around for my
neck NE I like to have a a nice scented
candle and medicinal things Throat Coat
throat losses I'm so boring but this
time I'm thinking of getting like a PS5
or a Nintendo switch to bring on I'm not
a big gamer but who knows this tour
might make me a big
gamer sit roll over boom B de roll over
[Music]
hey I feel like they know everything I
feel like we live our lives completely
on the internet this dude's about to
free jump out of are you Tom Cruz what's
going on that's a very tall very you I
don't know I feel like people know
everything what are you curious about I
guess that's a better question um what's
a fun
fact I know word totally sometimes
people forget that Idols are completely
human and people too we have the same
needs and the same wants and the same
everything see they agree they
completely agree I'm telling your
mom I think they just don't like me no
they do you guys they really like high
pitch noises too all right they really
like high pitch here we
[Music]
go he's like
what Waffle House waffle house is
[Music]
amazing the allar special you have to
add hash browns depending on how drunk
you might be you might get a Texas toast
thing super good
hey he's a little feisty
one maybe retired maybe not full-time
semi-retired I think probably riding a
lot and then maybe I'll have a cafe on
the beach somewhere and I just sling
coffees all day and appol spritzes and
like champagne and y'all can come visit
and hang out who
knows oh like negative 19 look at these
these puppies won't even hang out with
me I'm like begging them my RZ is on a
negative
today this one's about to jump oh oh my
gosh oh my gosh he wants to go fight
okay just be kind to your siblings they
like gnaw at each
other sorry I'm distracted I think
Barack Obama if I met Mr Obama I think
I'd freak out just full like hi sir nice
to to to meet you you
[Music]
I'd say none I think I'm I'm just a I'm
a soloist for life I think there was a
moment where oh my God he peed again
just little monsters I think there was a
time where I was like BTS but now
everybody's on doing their solo projects
right now so I'm like so right now I'm
in my solo era which position I would be
main dancer main singer and Main
[Music]
talker I think it's just that I get to
to create things that I love to create I
get to perform I get to tour I get to
play with puppies that have no interest
in hanging out with me I think the worst
thing is maybe like I know this has
gotten better but I think I used to have
like a lot of anxiety from it I felt
like I was on all the time and like
people were watching all the time and so
I've kind of taken a step back in terms
of the activity which has helped but um
that was probably like the hardest
thing this sorry this is the most ADHD
interview I've ever done and I have I
have ADH but I'm just like thinking
about so many
things yeah I do not want to live with
y'all I thought coming here I'd be like
hey I really want to get a puppy I don't
want one of y'all though y'all are
insane if any puppies out there looking
for like a really chill time hit me up
but like y'all are not chill y'all have
like negative chill negative 19 chill
y'all just like lowkey chew on
everything
anyways okay you're staying right here
you're a little instigator you're in
timeout aliens definitely do exist some
form of extraterrestrial life they may
be among us
now I have felt like the presence of
ghosts before where I like I've swear
like I've seen them and I'm just like I
convinced myself I just missa something
I also get like sleep paralysis where I
used to a gam out and whenever I did
that like I would see like ghosts or
demons and I just like to think that I'm
hallucinating but they were really scary
you need to chill dude chill good
[Music]
job I was part of a song for Monster X
called beast mode Jan reached out and
was like we can't figure out this song
can you come and help us figure out the
top line so I went and I did a lot of
the the top lining for that
song oh my God babies are so cute sorry
that was really exciting my nephew is so
cute I get regular video and photo
updates as of 2 days ago he started to
dance he shakes his hips like Shakira
and it's the funniest thing he has the
biggest brightest smile and he's just
like and it's the cutest thing and I
like to buy him a lot of really cool
clothes so if you see any really cool
fits it's from me hey you're here with
me well have you guys heard of Tik Tok
have you heard of uh oh my God hi hi
Riz have you heard of No
Cap and uh Snapchat the Snapchat and the
Tik Tok met the the get re I mean the
beat re and so that's like pretty fresh
like you guys probably don't know about
it but I do cuz I'm young hip and
[Music]
fresh honestly I tend to Wing a lot of
my interviews these days and it comes
from a place of genuine curiosity just
really trying to understand who the
person is that is where a lot of the
questions come from I know I know you
just got to chill for 2 seconds you're
doing such a good job I'll give you
treats after I just want you to like me
as much as I like you ow he's so
[Music]
vicious um it is really hard like
holding on to puppies it is actually
been very rewarding and great but also
very challenging and exhausting at times
but I don't know if it's because it's my
brothers but just more like running
businesses is hard but more than
anything I think what I what I
appreciate what we appreciate is bro I
don't want you either it's okay you just
stay over there I think we could trust
each other like we're family so like at
the end of the day if we fight if we
have a disagreement it's because we all
want the best for each other and that's
kind of where it comes from so yeah we
argue we fight sometimes what siblings
don't fight and argue y'all fight all
the time y'all got here and all y'all
done is
fight
uh sleep sleeping I heard is really cool
one day I hope to try it out also maybe
like Pottery Ceramics I tried it in
college I got a B minus so I'm not very
good how do you get a B minus in
Ceramics you do it like I do you really
don't show up to class so
yeah I uh have mhm I have four music
videos for this album and I wanted to
like make a short film essentially that
supported the story and the them names
behind the entire album the album is
called house on Hill I know I know you
love it right why are you shaking so
much why why why uh so we shot four
videos and they're all under the theme
of house on a hill which is about you
know really finding happiness and
wanting things that sometimes you can't
have oh now you want to come back
huh yeah you chilled right there
mm- let's see what you did do I feel
he's going to pounce on my face you want
to come here all right oh no okay bye
but yeah so essentially I'm playing four
or five characters in this short film
and uh you're so cute come here come
here okay fine never mind that's see um
what was a question oh yeah and so we
have like a like a 20 minute short film
very different concepts and visuals for
everyone so check it out I promise you
it's a lot of
fun
[Music]
okay you're here you can sit next to
your bro but you got to chill okay okay
biscuit okay you're going to
chill only one of you can leave only one
of you can leave you are not America's
Next Top Model goodbye what was question
what celebrity used to B groceries
nobody no attempts Jim
Carrey did anybody understand that Jim
in Korean is like Luggage So Jim
carrye
[Music]
I have not look everybody has sharded
before I don't care who you are where
you are what you do and how hot or
pretty you think you are you've sharded
and if you haven't you're lying to
yourself you've blacked it out of your
memory all right we're going to Traverse
my pants ready 1 2 3 and you're in but
yeah it's a thing that many of us don't
like to talk about I don't like to talk
about it I only talk about it cuz
somebody brought it up but at least you
know I'm not lying to you not being fake
yesterday I was telling my saw this real
of this like outdoor Explorer person
like intense like camping dude it was
this real that went viral I was sleeping
naked in my sleeping bag and I thought I
was letting out a fart I did not know it
was just diarrhea and my entire sleeping
B FL diara and he goes maybe it was the
fish that I ate it's like I don't know
what it was but it happens just embrace
it we're all human guys
well I thought Puppies made me happy oh
no right now it's okay earlier it was a
little stressful what makes me happy I
think my job I love to perform I love to
sing I love to go on tour and create
things I think that's one thing and then
just like spending time with the people
that I love that's the core that's the
essence of Happiness to
[Music]
me everybody buy a house buy it from me
I just want everybody to kind of reframe
what they think happiness is and like
why they're motivated to do what they do
and to find happiness in yourself and
your work and not based on the words of
others or those around you and I think
that's something that we tend to forget
especially today when so much of our
lives are LED online so visibly and
publicly so yeah do
you they're sleeping this is incredible
finally I'm trying to thank you would be
a great person
to have some throw somebody at me I
don't know who's your favorite artist
me you know what just going to throw it
out there cuz she's having a massive
tour she's probably having a great time
but I think she would do even better
with some puppies Taylor Swift I said it
I think I think you should do a puppy
interview hey guys do you see these
adorable little puppies that are
sleeping in my arms right now they're so
look at this they're available to adopt
right now at wag and walks you could
take one of these little puppies home
you could take all three of them home
all three sounds like a lot but just one
maybe two just make your day and your
life a little bit happier with these
adorable little puppies thanks for
having me on this puppy interview this
was the most chaotic interview I've done
I think ever my album is out right now
it's called house on Hill the lead
single is called only for a moment where
I'm dressed up pretty much like Neo from
The Matrix I'm also going on tour a lot
more music coming so please check it all
out be happy be healthy I'll see you
soon and someone adopt these puppy
thanks for having me guys bye they're
sleeping they're so cute they weren't
cute 10 minutes
[Music]
ago